When I was in college and money was tight,
I sold the log-in info for my World of Warcraft
character.
I remember that!
Didn’t you make like $350?
Way to game the system, babe!
I thought so, too.
But if you add up what it cost me to get there…
$50 to buy the game, $30 for the expansion
pack, $15 a month subscription fee… after
a few years of that, I’d sunk around $500
into that one game.
Not to mention the countless hours I’d spent
leveling up my character.
Yikes.
Well, at least you were able to mitigate the
loss a bit.
And you genuinely enjoyed playing it, right?
I think so… or was I just addicted?
Remember when buying a video game meant…
you owned it?
And you could play the whole thing without
spending one more dime?
Ah, the good old days!
That sales model has been largely replaced
by one that asks players to continuously pay
money throughout the course of the game.
And that economic transition has been very
lucrative for the games industry.
If you asked an 80s gamer to spend $500-$1000
on a video game, they’d probably choke on
their Hawaiian Punch.
But today, millions of players do that every
year, perhaps without even realizing it.
How did we get here?
The first “free-to-play” game was released
in South Korea in 1999 and over the next decade,
the idea spread across the globe, as developers
realized that capturing a large audience could
be more valuable than any purchase price--kind
of how the rest of the internet works.
[facebook, youtube, etc.].
Once you have their attention, then you can
advertise to them, or sell them little upgrades
and cosmetic items in-game.
These so-called “microtransactions” have
been incredibly profitable.
Remember Farmville?
This “free” game was making well over
$1 million a day from in-game upgrades and
boosts back in 2010.
The current free-to-play champ, Fortnite,
reportedly brings in over $2 million a day.
And according to surveys, 90% of people who
play the free online game League of Legends
have spent over $1000 each on the game.
And remember: unlike material goods, these
products cost the company nothing to manufacture.
Once the cost of design is offset, it’s
pure profit.
P: So how do these companies pull off this
nifty trick of getting people to overspend
on something that’s technically free?
Like most marketing, the strategy is mostly
based on exploiting the customers’ psychology.
First of all, if you want people to keep spending,
you need them to keep playing, which means
these games have to be open-ended and addictive.
Forget beating the final boss or rescuing
the princess, now it’s all about climbing
the leaderboard, raising your level, or expanding
your kingdom--objectives that could theoretically
go on forever.
And the distribution of rewards--like unlocking
a new weapon or a bigger castle---has been
carefully crafted in look, sound, and timing,
to deliver a powerful dopamine rush that players
will crave again and again.
Developers also know that as much as people
like winning, they hate losing more.
In economics, this is called “loss aversion,”
and it leads people to spend more and more
money just to avoid that terrible feeling
of being a loser.
In Candy Crush, once you run out of moves,
you’ve technically lost.
But you can use one “Lollypop” to get
three extra turns.
And you’ve only got a few seconds to decide
- hurry before it’s too late!
This might not seem that different from the
earliest days of video games, where players
could pump another quarter into the arcade
cabinet to keep playing.
But at least you could run out of quarters,
and have time to rethink your life goals on
the way to the change machine.
Today, those little arcade cabinets we keep
in our pockets are often linked to our bank
accounts, so you can keep continuing and continuing
until there’s nothing left.
Quarters also have the advantage of saying
exactly how much they’re worth, right on
the front.
Many of today’s games require you to convert
your money into unfamiliar currencies, like
Fortnite’s V-bucks or League of Legends’
Riot Points.
They know people are more likely to spend
money if they don’t know exactly how much
they’re spending.
The newest innovation in microtransactions
seems to be inspired from the casinos of Las
Vegas: loot boxes.
Instead of selling items outright, some games
ask you to buy a mystery box that might contain
a super rare level 20 Energy Sword… or a
worthless stick.
Loot Boxes, card-packs and other random-chance
items exploit what economists call “variable
rate enforcement”.
Our brains love unpredictable rewards.
Just like with slot machines, the dopamine
rush is more intense when the reward is a
surprise.
So opening a loot box and finding that Hot
Pink Top Hat you always wanted can feel more
like a win than buying it outright--even if
you spent more to get it.
Do these strategies work on everyone?
No.
But they don’t have to.
A study in 2016 found that almost half of
all spending on mobile game microtransactions
came from 0.19% of players, with a very small
number (known in the industry as “whales”)
spending thousands on their favorite games.
So, in effect, these companies are okay with
most people enjoying their product for free,
as long as they can soak a handful of super-addicted
gamers.
Unfortunately, a lot of these “whales”
turn out to be “calves.”
(That’s what you call a baby whale.)
Yep, children are uniquely susceptible to
these psychological tricks, probably due to
their impulsivity and lack of understanding
of what they’re actually doing.
You’ve probably heard the horror stories.
The 17 year old who racked up $7,500 on his
dad’s credit card for microtransactions
in FIFA ‘16.
Or the 7 year old who spent over $6,000 on
Jurassic World for iPad.
Game developers typically refuse to refund
these charges and still have not done much
in the way of child protections.
However, there has been some push-back from
parents, legislators and gamers alike.
EA tweaked its rewards system for the popular
Star Wars-themed game Battlefront 2 in response
to player criticism.
The game heavily advertised Darth Vader and
Luke Skywalker as playable characters, but
one gamer calculated that unless you’re
willing to pay for shortcuts, unlocking the
characters would require 40 hours of in-game
grinding… each.
And legislators in states and countries across
the world have considered regulating loot
boxes like a form of gambling--especially
now that secondary markets have sprung up
where people can sell the rare contents of
those loot boxes for hundreds or thousands
of real dollars.
And indeed, research has pointed towards a
link between the amount one spends on loot
boxes and the likelihood of having a gambling
problem.
If you’re a parent, you might consider only
buying games for your kids that are “Pay-Once-and-Play,”
or at the very least avoid having any credit
card accounts linked to gaming devices.
If you are a consumer of video games yourself,
remember that enjoying a game is not the same
thing as being addicted.
And like most non-essential expenses, you
should keep track of exactly how much you’re
spending on it a month.
Microtransaction purchases are designed to
be impulsive and thoughtless, so just being
aware of what you’re doing is still the
best meta.
The best what?
Such a noob.
Okay stop.
And that’s our two cents!